une journée pour allier le sport et le
bien manger c'est l'objectif de la
manifestation organisée par l'usep et
l'urss au parc du colosse à saint-andré
le conseil départemental étaient
également présents à travers le conseil
départemental des jeunes et la direction
de la vie éducative un partenariat
évident pour que toutes les forces
s'allient pour faire passer un maximum
de messages aux plus jeunes
le but de cette journée c'est raymond
témoin m une manifestation commune entre
l'usap qui est le secteur sportif
scolaire avec d'enseignement mais
qu'également le sport à l'école primaire
publique et l'urss qui touche le sport
scolaire que la vieillissait l'idée
c'est d'associer ces deux structures qui
gèrent le sport scolaire dans une
activité pendant une journée mais je
dirais diverses d'activités
divertissantes d'initiation des
pratiques sportives mais également une
initiation à des domaines tels que le
développement durable que la sécurité la
santé puisque le spa pour nous n'est
qu'un moyen d'éducation
c'est un moyen de toucher d'autres
domaines la citoyenneté le conseil
départemental des jeunes qui travaillent
cette année sur le sport l'alimentation
la nutrition souhaité organiser une
journée d'information les élus
départementaux jeunes ont donc décidé de
s'associer à l'urss et du cep pour
mettre en place cette action
du coup on a collaboré avec
les partenaires russes aient pu bien né
cesse et maintenant on est un petit peu
dans l'organisation n'a participé à des
séances de travail et pour pouvoir
organiser la manifestation autres
partenaires présents pour cette journée
l'association adm 9 7 4 qui informe les
enfants sur la nutrition et sur
l'importance de l'activité physique pour
se prémunir des maladies chroniques
comme le diabète ou l'obésité
c'est un vrai problème de santé à la
réunion tout particulièrement puisque on
a des taux d'obésité de diabète qui sont
plus important qu'en métropole et donc
ça nous paraît très important de pouvoir
sensibiliser les jeunes
rapidement plusieurs ateliers
d'information mais également les
initiations pour découvrir différents
sports
ici ce sont les rugbyman qui passe le
ballon ovale aux plus jeunes pour les
initier à ce sport où le partage
l'effort et la solidarité rejoignent les
valeurs citoyennes
ça me rappelle la paix
prix remis sa volonté des valeurs de
solidarité et puis tout le monde on a sa
place dans le rugby les petits et les
grands les échos sont donc ça rejoint
totalement à l'esprit de la journée
citoyens une autre activité tout aussi
méconnu
puis la lutte et là c'est une pointure
qui donne les conseils de champion de
france de lutte himself venir dans ce
sport car c'est pas que tout le monde
quand ils entendent le mot lutte
il croit que c'est un sport avec
beaucoup de contacts tout ça mais c'est
pas un sport qui fait mal
la citoyenneté in valeurs défendues par
le département qui à travers le conseil
départemental des jeunes de toucher le
plus grand nombre de jeunes citoyens
le département de la réunion a été le
premier département à mettre en place
justement un procès général des jeunes
en 1989 et aujourd'hui oui effectivement
nous comptons un peu plus de cent
cinquante six jeunes issus des quatre
coins de l'île à vie pour justement
mener des actions en faveur en faveur
des publics démunis des actions pour
qu'ils puissent vraiment serré et et
voir un petit peu par rapport à la
difficulté problématique de la société
actuelle et il faut savoir que nous
encourageons bien sûr et moi hong kong
vice président délégué à l'éducation
j'encourage ce genre d'initiative
surtout de ce jeune public
une journée placée aussi sous le signe
de la détente et de la danse dernières
tendances
la zumba est là l'atelier a fait le
plein
sur commande